عشاق كره القدم يترقبون حامل الكاس بين
الارجنتين وفرنسا رغم الخلافات انباء عن
دعوات هارون
ملكه جمال فرنسا
[موسيقى]
نهائي كاس العالم على ملعب العاصمه
القطريه
لنتائج لنتيجه المباراه ويتنافس المنتخبان
على تتويج به نجمه الثالثه
نجم الكره
منتخب
لكن بعد انتهاء كاس العالم سيعود الثنائي
الى اللاعب معا في باريس سان جيرمان
كاس العالم
ونبقى في اجواء المونديال حيث كشفت صحيفه
الفرنسيه
ريال مدريد ومنتخب فرنسا رفض دعوه الرئيس
ايمانويل ماكروب السفر رفقه الى العاصمه
القطريه لحضور نهائي كاس العالم امام
الارجنتين واثر غياب اللاعب الفرنسي عن
المونديال جده
انضمامه لقائمه المباراه النهائيه امام
الارجنتين بعد تعافيه من الاصابه
الى بريطانيا هذه المره فا رغم اصداء
المسلسل الوثائقي الامير هاري وزوجته
الافعال السلبيه التي خلفها بالمجتمع
البريطاني الان الملك جاز الثالث ماده غصن
الزيتون الى الدوخ والدوخه رغم حمله
المسلسل الانتقادات للعائله الملكه فبحسب
مصادر اكدت لصحيفه البريطانيه من الملك
ابله وزوجته بانهما سيكون مرحب بهما في
حفله تنصيبه الرسمي ملكا في صيف عام 2013
وفي الولايات المتحده تساعد السلطات الى
تحويل حاضر للايجار
في الاسماك القرش الى قانون الموسم
لتلبيه الطلب عليها في الصين
[موسيقى]
القرش في الولايات المتحده
التي تؤثر على ملايين اسماك القرش سنويا
ونصل الى الختام حيث توجد الشابه الفرنسيه
وهي طالبه اتصالات تبلغ 18 عاما توجت ملكه
جمال فرنسا عام 2023 وشهدت المسابقه هذا
العام تخفيفا لشروط الاهليه المطلوبه
للمتسابقات عندما كانت في السابق تفرض بان
يتراوحها عمرهن بين 18 و 28 عاما ولا يقل
طول قامتهن عن واحد فاصله 70 مره
من دون اطفال لكن بحصلوا شروط الجديده متى
يمكن لاي فرنسيه تبلغ 18 عاما وما فوق
المشاركه في المسابقه دون اي شروط مرتبطه
بطول القامه او الوضع العائلي كما بعد
مسموحا وجوده او شام البحر على الجسم
للمره الاولى في تاريخ المسابقه العريقه
[موسيقى]